tom silverstein the Milwaukee
journal-sentinel reporter the Packers
beat writer join us on the show
Tom I I don't want to add to this but it
feels like there's just a little bit
under the water here with Aaron Rodgers
is is something rising to the surface
here that we don't know about well I
think it's something that's kind of been
festering a little bit during the off
season
that's Rodgers feels that it has
affected him and he's had no input into
it but I don't I don't know if it's
going to result in him you know breaking
off negotiations with the Packers on a
contract extension that might last the
rest of his career I think there's too
much at stake for both sides I think
it's just a little bit of him expressing
his frustration over not being consulted
on things that he feels he should be
consulted on but which ones should he
have been consulted on well you know I
wrote a column on it and I felt none I
thought that Brian Goethe currents the
first few general manager has no
obligation to make those decisions and
there's a number of reasons why because
first of all you know your player
shouldn't be determining who you keep
and who you don't because they have an
emotional investment in everything and
then do you want Aaron Rodgers to be the
general manager so that or the
impression in the locker room that he's
the general manager and he could be the
one who determines whether you come and
go so I think gudykunst is following Ted
Thompson's model which is you know when
when Brett Favre K it was there and
Thompson came in he felt that Brett
Favre had way too much power in the
organization in the locker room and he
worked to cut that out and was not going
to sign free agents to please Brett
Favre so he would come back and I think
that's kind of
the tone that good conscience taking
yeah I'm looking at this and you know
granted Alex Van Pelt is let go that's
the quarterback coach so I'd understand
where Rodgers would at least like to be
given a heads up Jordy Nelson their
friendship that you'd like to be given a
heads up but I don't want to go to Aaron
Rodgers to say who do you think we
should bring in to replace Jordy Nelson
you know I I think that's dangerous and
I go back to Michael Jordan the greatest
player of all time
he he wanted to be consulted he wanted
to make moves and finally they said no
Jerry Krause is gonna make the moves and
we know what happened after that
so I understand it but was he salty how
salty was Rodgers over the Jordy Nelson
and Alex Van Pelt situations well I
think I think he was privately you know
taken aback no Alex Van Pelt but that's
kind of a complex situation because Alex
and PAL had made it clear that he wanted
to go for an offensive coordinators
position but that's what he was looking
for and I think he has allowed his
Olivia loudest contract to expire and
McCarthy requires guys to roll over to a
second year every year so that they have
two year contracts and he didn't and he
didn't get an offensive coordinators job
and I think McCarthy couldn't get a two
year commitment from him or he just
decided was best to move on
regardless outside helps also
represented by the same agent as Aaron
Rodgers and there's some complication
there too I mean does does Mike McCarthy
take that advice from Aaron Rodgers
knowing that you know there's a
connection there - I think McCarthy had
to make his own decision now he could
have definitely kept Rodgers in the you
know just in the know about it and
saying
Goethe critics could have done the same
with Nelson and just said look I'm
cutting Jordy Nelson you just want you
to know I don't think that was done that
smooth some things over but III honestly
don't think it would have been smart to
ask him for his you know input on
whether that was a good idea you know
personnel guys have to make their own
decisions on personnel any chance Dez
Bryant comes in I don't see it
III don't I think the Packers the wind
up drafting someone fairly high maybe in
the second round you know Jimmy Graham
is a is basically a wide receiver yeah
and so he's gonna play a lot and he's
going to be a big factor in that offense
and so I think they don't really want to
go down that road I think from cellar
camps kept standpoint they can't do it
and then from a locker room standpoint
I'm not sure if they want to do it
either so I would be really surprised as
it happen Tom thanks for joining us you
know it was quiet here leading up to the
draft and all of a sudden the Rodgers
stuff came out and then Tom Brady stuff
came out so gives us something to talk
about before the draft so the gift that
keeps on giving you know thank you Tom
you got there let's uh tom silverstone
he works for the Milwaukee
journal-sentinel Packers beat writer for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]